I believe a lot of us want it a lot of
us pray forward but we don't accept it
what I mean is a lot of human beings
it's like a pit bull tied to a plastic
chair and they believe this plastic
chair is keeping them there when all
they have to do
it's use that power in that strength to
pull that chair from under but I too was
once that same man that man that set in
pity and believed that his life could
not be greater than it was let me tell
you a story three years ago was the man
who set on side of a turkey Hill gas
station no money no car no phone no hope
this kid wanted to commit suicide this
kid wanted to give up on life and one
day God did something amazing one day
this kid woke up and he walked into a
school car right in the intermediate
high school he acts the principal
can I speak to five kids and she gave
him that opportunity 10 minutes later
when he walked out of that school he got
a phone call and that phone call said
how much do you charge to speak this kid
said I don't know
but I'm willing to do it
three weeks later that car deaf young
man into a school to speak
I found a 500 high school students
mind you before this man walked into
this school
he wanted to commit suicide he wanted to
take his life
when this kid walked into that school
and he's smoking for those five hundred
children from that day on that man
traveled the world that man aspired
people
from Australia to Nigeria
[Music]
he also went on to speak to NFL teams he
we don't want to make history in Milan
for Philip I don't my love fashion
[Music]
and it's starting belief
you see that man was me we're not
watching my mother do heroin and growing
up watching my father get incarcerated
in my uncle getting a concentrated
belief was all I had
you see to some people belief is a
choice but for other people belief it's
the only thing they got
[Music]
because the night they stand in the
malls with no meals the night
that is watching people die and people
walk out of his life that man is not
supposed to
but what that man developed in the
struggle of life
[Music]
he realized that no matter how big your
house is how big your vocabulary is it's
all about what you have
you say ladies and gentlemen the world
believed that you have to get you pills
degree but the trophy is your degrees
your gifts
[Applause]
[Music]
you gotta ask yourself
what it is you're willing to dedicate
your life to
and what it is that you're willing to
believe me
[Music]
you see I got a saying when I say
weren't for your purpose and not the
money I mean men
I mean
[Applause]
you got to believe in impossible
[Music]
because you are extraordinary
it's someone out there that was just
like me sitting on the computer
at a free hotel watching Evan Carmichael
you to ten
studying all the greats because he
didn't have the money to pay for all
these big program
and I want to know I want you to know
King just watching that show just
watching at you 210 what they say
touches your heart and you believe
[Applause]
because you're watching a young man my
hits for the eight years the dating
buried his mother to a heroin overdose
Bob in the penitentiary and I'm growing
into one of the biggest speakers just
world has ever seen
I tell people every day no no one is
bigger or better than you it just worked
they just believe
in the process
because the process called me home
I asked individuals all the time
what did you do
you born in darkness
everyone around was telling you
trash
the scoop
your mother passes away of a heroin
overdose you never have a father I never
learned the rules of life the lessons
that can help us take us to the next
level
see when you walked it on projects
are you walking through life any-any
you gotta take a look in the mirror you
got to talk to yourself
[Music]
you gotta ask yourself where are you
willing to take to defeat parvo
to defeat the pains of life
are you willing to walk in darkness
anybody don't know
[Music]
are you willing to wake up at 4 in the
morning the screen to the Sun
well [ __ ] go get that belongs to me
are you willing to go without meals are
you willing
to make the Lucifer
that's the ton of the breakers
you see belief
is the foundation
is what drives us all
but I want you guys to understand this
one thing that iTunes you
I too was a person with the crash today
[Applause]
I too was a person who buried his mother
I too was a man that slept outside
let me tell you something
the moment you lay your head on the car
key getaway consumption
but a lot of people for god
that's a home
that's a fight
my best example is just like this ladies
and gentlemen I want you to remember
this statement in this
[Music]
you ever been walking in your
neighborhood and the dog breaks loose
and when his dog breaks loose you see
them on your tail and you start to run
you ever notice how fast
[Music]
do you ever notice how hard you fight
when your life is on the line but I want
you to understand this
right
evil
and the only person that's gonna keep
you breathing is you it's gonna be
somebody to watch this video I think
they're nothing they think they can
never live a real life with a family at
a dinner table or taking family
vacations or walking them into college
the first date
[Music]
you see ladies and gentlemen whoever you
believe me and you believe in me I
believe in God
and the reason I believe in God is
because when I had no drawers he gave me
underwear when I had no food he gave me
food when I had no career he gave me a
career I was a special way of story that
gave Pontiac Northern high school in
Michigan I used to skip classes because
I was embarrassed to read
and I used to think
that
that was punished
what I realized Kaizen clothes
the pain
your brain
we'll be your biggest blessing
don't you quit believing on me anything
is possible if you believe it is
[Music]
walk towards your destiny
that plastic chairs not heavy it's only
a lose doubt is only a lose
but leaf
it's real nice too
we will change your life and the great
words of my brother Kevin Kahn
man
and made me believe I'd be wondering
where two speakers over
thank you into the world damn it
what's up man hey I love you brother
and I tell you all the time I tell you
this all the time you might not you
might not know what I'm building but
every email everything you send me bro
I'm learning I'm taking it broke
yesterday I got a car bro I might be at
an event in Miami on the stage with Les
Brown Eric Thomas new school versus the
old school and and because of you King I
spoke my way let me show you something I
was in the cell see when I when I met
you right
when I first let me show you something
I'm in a gated community now nice ten
I'll show you something
I spoke my well to shelter and I'm in a
gated community now you did this
you inspire the King you inspired a kid
this is what you do I'm from the slums
of Pontiac Michigan this is what you
doing Evan although another man I love
you I love it man I'm living there I
love it I love it
brothers for life
I can't wait to meet you man I can't
wait to meet you when I meet you I
promise you Evan
mark my words twenty-eight years old
today by the age of 35 I'll be one of
the top speakers in the world and I
promise you that and remember I told you
I told you that I already know dude I
already know dude that's gonna happen
faster than seven years where were you
based man where you baseline okay I'm
doing a US tour early next year but
we're not hitting Atlanta so next time I
come down no I was homeless in
Mississauga I moved to Toronto back
after my mom passed away over heroin
overdose I was lost King and a
bodybuilding trainer that went to school
with my mom and moved over there and
basically he she used to take up on went
when people used to bully him
so basically he brung me down to Canada
changed my life he went to jail for tax
evasion I end up sleeping in the UH the
doctor in Mississauga down in the train
station I used to go to good life gym
they used to let me continue to workout
for free
and I remember Zoo
said it was better for me to be to be
honest on the street than the be back in
the hood a Pontiac Michigan because
where my father was a huge heroin dealer
and he it was so much chaos and you know
in the neighborhoods they always look at
us as drug dealers people who need to
sell dope people who need to do crazy
things but I wanted to break that mold
and what happened was man God guided me
this entire way everything man I'll tell
you you gotta walk you out if you ever
in Pennsylvania the reading or me uh
Abraham Lincoln hotel downtown Reading
Pennsylvania is where I watched your
time I used to sit in there for hours
and everyman your words do you know you
know something about you man your
humility it's how you interact me that's
what you taught me cuz if you act like
when you when you when you interact with
your people they love you they don't
become fans their family their lifetime
people that always file you always look
up to you I just want you to know I'm I
can't thank you enough man do god you'd
almost bring me to tears I love listen
to next time next time in Pennsylvania
we're gonna do we're gonna do a collab
together at that hotel we're gonna make
that happen I don't know what I'm in
Pennsylvania next I was just there I
want my one picture so I can blow up and
put it on my wall man I gotta I got a
look at you I got a look at us every day
because every you did it
you you did it man you inspiring there's
so many kids around the world
you have no idea every man you everyday
you post every day you get out why you
think for two or three years I woke up
and I post it every day you've been
saying up for three years get up and
post every day every day get on your
grind and evidence I did it and I built
by the end of the year I'll be over 100
million total views on YouTube guys to a
single rise king
it's like eighty six thousand and six
days it's sold 1500 copies in five days
or hygiene nice man no it's getting
there it's getting there I love it dude
it's just a start just a start man just
to start just a start keep going man
thanks man if everybody watching stay
tuned for a collab it's coming soon
all right much louder thank you calling
a dude thank you thank you for the
energy one was volume you you have the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon if
you want more William King Hollis go
check out his channel the link is right
there next to me tell him Evan sent you
continue to believe and I'll see you
there